let's now attempt to find a solution for
the logistic differential equation and
we already found some constant solutions
we can think through that a little bit
just as a little bit of review from the
last few videos so this is the T axis
and this is the N axis we already saw
that if n of 0 if at time equals 0 our
population is zero there is no one to
reproduce and this this differential
equation is consistent with that because
if n is 0 this thing is going to be 0
and so our rate of change is going to be
0 with respect to time and so our
population just won't change it'll just
stay at 0 which is nice because that's
what would actually happen in a real
population so that gives us the constant
solution that n of T is equal to 0
that's one solution to this differential
equation not that interesting 0
population will never grow or change the
other constant solution is what if our
population stay started at the maximum
of what the environment could could
sustain and in that situation this term
is going to be K over K which is 1 1
minus 1 is 0 and so in there the
population would also not change we just
stay at K and so the rate of change
would just stay at 0 so that's another
constant solution that we start we start
at the maximum population and then this
differential equation X tells us a
scenario that never changes but we said
hey look well there could be something
interesting that happens if we if our
initial condition which we called n
sub-nought that's our n of 0 at time
equals 0 if we start someplace in
between maybe closer much below our our
eventual ceiling I guess because if
we're a lot below our eventual ceiling
this thing is going to be a small
fraction this thing is going to be close
to 1 and so the rate of change is going
to be pretty close to being proportional
to n which is going to and when we're
thinking that we can kind of it might
look something like that as n increases
our rate of change increases but then as
n approaches K this thing is going to
approach 1 this thing is going to
approach 0 and so it's going to
overwhelm this and our rate of changes
might is going to approach 0 and so we
could imagine a scenario where we
asymptote where we asked some towed
towards K and for let's see if we can
solve this to find this
this n of T this n of T to finding the
actual analytic expression for this n of
T right over here because this is
interesting this is what could could be
used to model populations that would be
more consistent with a Malthusian the
mindset so let's see if we can do that
and to do that we just realized this is
a completely different this is a
separable differential equation and
we're assuming is a function of T we're
going to solve for an N of T that
satisfies this and so we just have to
separate it from the explicit T's but
there are no explicit T's here so it's
quite easy to do so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take this part right
over here I'm going to divide both sides
by that I'm going to leave the R on the
right-hand side it'll make things I
think a little bit easier as we as we
try to solve for n of T so let me just
do that so this is going to be equal to
1 over n times 1 minus n over K 1 minus
n over K times DN DT times DN DT is
equal to R is equal to R and another way
you could have we could think about it
there well actually let me just let me
just continue to tackle it this way so
we get we get that and now what I want
to do is take the antiderivative of both
sides with respect to T well this is
pretty straight forward that's this
going to be RT times some constant but
what is this going to be this kind of
this messy thing and maybe if we could
break this out if we can expand this
into two fractions do a little bit of
partial fraction expansion maybe we can
come up with an expression that's a
little bit easier to find the
antiderivative of and so I'm hoping that
I can find an A and a B where a over N
plus B over 1 minus n over K is equal to
this business is equal to 1 over N times
1 minus n over K let's see if we can
find an A and a B this is just partial
fraction expansion if this looks
unfamiliar to you I encourage you to
review that part on Khan Academy do a
search for a partial fraction expansion
Khan Academy so how do we do it well
just add these two right over here so
this if we take the sum right over here
this is going to be a times this which
is a minus a over K n plus B times this
plus BN over the product of these two so
it's just going to be n times 1 minus n
over K one way to think about it I just
multiply the numerator in the
denominator of this one by 1 minus n
minus 1 minus n over K so a times 1
minus n over K is that n times 1 minus n
of K is that and I multiply the
numerator and denominator of this both
by n BN and n times that and then I
added the 2 now that I had this the same
denominator so that's just adding
fractions with unlike denominators it's
going to be equal to this 1 over N times
1 minus n over K and now we could try to
think well what is what is a and B going
to be equal to what can they be equal to
well I have a constant term here I don't
have any N term here I could say that
maybe I have a 0 times an N it actually
helps things a little bit because maybe
we could say that this thing that this
Plus this which other coefficients on n
are going to sum up to 0 and that this
which is our a is going to be equal to 1
that's pretty nice so we could say that
a is equal to 1 a is equal to 1 and then
if a is equal to 1 we have negative 1
over K negative 1 over k plus B plus B
is equal to 0 well what's B going to be
well B would be equal to 1 1 over K so
we can rewrite this as we can rewrite it
as 1 over N 1 over N 1 over n plus 1
over n plus 1 over k plus 1 over K over
over all over let me just do this over 1
minus n over K 1 minus n over K over K
and then and then x times DN DT D and DT
is equal to is equal to R so I just did
a little bit of partial fraction
expansion and I like give myself a
little bit of real estate let me clear
this out you can rewind the video and
review that if you find it necessary so
let's do that and so how does this help
us well yeah you know I kind of you
probably might be recognizing the
antiderivative of 1 over N and you might
even see this so let's let's just think
through this a little bit we know the
antiderivative 1 over n is the natural
log just in a new color is the natural
log of the absolute value of N and we
can see the derivative of that with
respect to N is equal to 1 over N and if
we were to find the derivative of this
with respect to T derivative with
respect to T of the natural log of the
absolute value of n is equal to this is
going to be the derivative of this with
respect to n times the derivative of n
with respect to T times DN DT and we
could do the same thing over here notice
I have I have an expression what would
be the derivative of this expression
right over here it would be negative 1
over K if I'm taking the derivative with
respect to n it would be negative 1 over
K I have a positive 1 over K here and I
can even make it negative I can I can
turn this I can clear this out of the
way instead of having a positive there I
could have a I guess I could say a
double negative so a double negative I
haven't changed the value of it and
notice now this is the derivative of
this which makes it very nice for you
substitution or you might be already
used to doing this thing in your head
and so we know that the derivative with
respect to n let me write this in a new
color we know that the derivative with
respect to n of the natural log of 1
minus
n over K once again this comes straight
out of the chain rule it's going to be
the derivative of this with respect to n
which is negative 1 over K times the
derivative of this whole thing with
respect to this thing which is times 1
over 1 minus n over K which is exactly
we have what we have over here but if I
were to take the derivative of this with
respect to T so the derivative with
respect to T of the natural log of 1
minus n over K it's going to be the
derivative of this with respect to N
which is that which is what we just
found it's going to be this so copy and
paste it's going to be that it's going
to be that times the derivative of n
with respect to T just straight out the
chain rule DN DT well notice we have a
DN DT we can multiply it times each of
these things and actually why not let's
just do that just to make it clear
because this is really you know this
isn't so much differential equations but
sometimes some of the calculus that we
learned not too long ago and even
frankly some of the algebra it's nice to
not skip steps so if I distribute this
and it pastes whoops I want to copy and
paste so copy and paste so I have that
and then I have and then I have Ike and
I can copy and paste so that I'm just
distributing I'm just distributing this
business right over here so I get that
now let me clean it up a little bit so I
have that right over here and of course
we have this being equal to R if I take
the antiderivative of this with respect
to T well I'm just going to get I'm just
going to get this I am just going to get
this as the anti I'm just going to get
this and plus or this minus this minus
this
right over that so let's do that let's
take the antiderivative with respect to
T so the left-hand side I'm going to get
the natural log this the antiderivative
of that with respect to T is the natural
log of the absolute value of N and then
minus the antiderivative of this with
respect to T is the natural log the
natural log of the absolute value of 1
minus n over K is equal to 1 and let's
not forget let's say and we're going to
have some constant here I want to find a
pretty general solution let's call it C
1 is equal to the antiderivative of this
with respect to T is R times T maybe
plus some other constant plus some other
constant just like that and now I'm
going to assume that my n of T meets
this this assumption right over here and
so I'm going to assume I'm going to so
assuming assuming assume assume n of T
is going to be less than K and greater
than 0 that means that this thing this n
is always going to be positive and if n
is always between 0 and K that means
that this thing is always going to be
positive and so that helps me clear
things up a little bit actually let me
do it in this color that helps me get
rid of that helps me get rid of helps me
get rid of that I can instead throw some
parentheses here and why don't I
subtract the c1 from both sides so let
me that would get rid of it here so edit
cut and paste so I have the c1 there and
I know I'm overriding my own work which
is not making it look as clean as
possible I'm just trying to clean it up
a little bit and I have an arbitrary
constant that I haven't really solved
for yet minus another constant let me
just call this some other constant let
me just call it general C so let me just
call this let me just call this C
clear and I'm just going to call that
see I am just going to call that see and
I can even simplify this a little bit
but actually I just realized I'm 13
minutes into this video which is longer
than I like to do so let's continue this
in the next video I was getting excited
because I'm so close I'm so close to
solving for an N of T that satisfies our
logistic differential equation very very
exciting